okay so today I want to start the show
by talking about the strategy of the
2020 Democratic primary so I'm not gonna
focus so much on political issues today
as far as what positions do I agree with
and don't I agree with if you've been
watching this show if you've been
listening to the podcast or the radio
show for a while you know that my
politics for example are to the left of
Joe Biden so I would like a more
progressive nominee I like Bernie
Sanders I like Elizabeth Warren from the
sort of more well-known candidates I
like some of Andrew Yang's ideas
although I have questions about the way
he would implement some of them but the
point is Joe Biden is a Hillary Clinton
centrist and while I think Joe Biden's a
great debater as I've said before that
doesn't mean that I actually want Joe
Biden to be President of the United
States given other options
Joe's politics are to my right but I've
made it really clear that if Biden's the
nominee I'm not gonna vote for him in
the primary but if he wins the primary
Biden's the nominee I'm sure as hell
voting for Joe Biden over Donald Trump
but that's the sort of political stuff I
don't want to talk so much about the
politics but what instead is the
strategy of running another scent
centrist Democrat against Donald Trump
after what happened in 2016 with Hillary
Clinton one of the biggest red flags for
me when it comes to strategy from Joe
Biden came on day one of Joe Biden's
campaign where he didn't really do an
announcement where he presents his ideas
his platform he didn't even tout too
many of his credentials which are
actually numerous although they still
don't make him anything other than a
centrist Biden focused on
Charlottesville and Trump so we'll see
whether this changes as Joe Biden keeps
campaigning but his opening statement
his announcement video was a let's
defeat Trump speech which to me is
already the wrong strategy and is having
a is triggering in my mind memories of
some elements of 2016 focusing on let's
defeat Trump is like running a campaign
on we will indict Trump
we will impeach Trump leave that up to
the current elected officials in the
House and Senate let them figure out our
impeachment proceedings the right thing
is impeachment debate the right thing
25th amendment whatever right if you
think Trump should be impeached say it
as some candidates have said but the
campaign can't just be about Trump is
bad on charlottesville and I'm going to
be better so problem one for Biden in
strategy is that so far it's been hugely
about the platform is get rid of Donald
Trump and I'm the person says Joe Biden
to get rid of Donald Trump and he may be
but this is not the right way to go
about it so that's problem number one
problem number two with Biden's campaign
is that Biden is playing around the
edges and not with the plot or to use
like a literature analogy Biden is
running a campaign but he's touting only
the prologue and the acknowledgments
page at the end of the book rather than
the actual substance right and what I
mean by that is this recent example
Biden talked about finding a middle
ground on climate change that's a pro
status quo establishment framing finding
a middle ground on crime it change
climate changes a crisis we need
systemic change to deal with that issue
Arwa Maddow II has a really good article
about this in The Guardian Biden is not
someone who has said because I don't
think he believes that we need
significant systemic change in America
to solve the major issues of our time
those being campaign finance how
politics is financed climate change the
massive inequality that has created all
sorts of over class and underclass
structures in America including on
health care including on education
including on just basic you know
forwarding cost of living Sanders and
Warren are not just offering progressive
policies at the micro-level which I like
but the macro that they are presenting
Bernie may be slightly more than than
Elizabeth Warren admittedly is that we
need systemic change we need systemic
change when it comes to the primary
power relationships that exist in the
United States
Biden proposes some policies but it's
all about let's get back
center-left Democratic establishment
rule status quo where we sort of deal
with a few symptoms around the edges we
get rid of a president that won't take
white nationalism seriously and this
type of thing and these things are
important but they're not the plot right
yes Trump has a loud extremism to fester
it would be great to get rid of Trump
and put in place anyone who would
immediately change tone on that issue
but that's not a platform and it's
certainly not particularly progressive
so what we need to do is prevent Biden
from being Hillary 2020 whether he wins
or loses the primary okay if you don't
like Biden's politics do what I'm gonna
do which is you vote in the primary for
somebody else who's more progressive if
a more progressive candidate doesn't win
and a centrist candidate wins
whether it's Biden or somebody else I
still think that they can beat Trump
they just need to play their cards right
they need to play their cards right in
the key states that Hillary narrow
narrowly lost Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Michigan there are others Trump isn't
that popular well punch my mic because
I'm getting so wound up here Trump isn't
that popular in those states he can be
beaten but if it's going to be a
centrist Democrat they actually need to
run their campaign correctly and it's
not clear at all that Joe Biden is doing
that at this point in time even though
he's polling very very well if Biden
wins the primary and he's polling well
then what we need to do on the
progressive left is make sure that Biden
runs the correct centrist Democrat
campaign so that if it's Biden he might
actually defeat Donald Trump not losing
to trump like Hillary did in 2016
interference and DNC meddling aside
everyday I am seeing more and more signs
that Biden is running a Hillary 2020
campaign effectively and this is a real
problem and we're gonna have to continue
thinking about what the strategy is
going to be during the primary and
what's the strategy if Joe Biden is
ultimately the nominee I will vote for
him over Trump there's no question about
that not even for a second I am NOT
going to be part of the problem of those
who may help to put Donald Trump in the
White House for a second term but we've
got to keep talking about this for sure
today's program is sponsored in part by
our friends over at Loch Ness crypto
dot-com the team is based in Boise Idaho
and they've made it their mission to
help just everyday people navigate the
world of cryptocurrency and they've been
doing it since 2012 they've actually
been teaching a course about
cryptocurrency at the Boise State
computer science department for years
and they've taken that curriculum and
sort of packed it into an easy to digest
course that's now available to anybody
who wants it called the cryptocurrency
starter kit and this is the type of
thing that crypto has really been
lacking and it's one of the reasons we
we maybe haven't seen adoption of
currencies like Bitcoin and others on a
larger scale normal people who are not
tech experts need a step-by-step guide
that's easy to understand about how they
can get involved with cryptocurrency in
a way that is sort of safe and
manageable and that's what the
cryptocurrency starter kit provides it's
a five part video series which includes
how to safely obtain cryptos where to
set up your accounts how to protect
those accounts from hackers importantly
how to move crypto into physical
hardware wallets and also how to just
prepare for the future of the space you
also get a free physical Hardware wallet
it's sort of like a flash drive where
you can safely store your Bitcoin or
other Kryptos offline and you also get
one hour of one on one phone or Skype
mentoring with one of lochness Kryptos
experts they're the only company in the
crypto space that offers a service like
this and it all comes with the
cryptocurrency starter kit they have a
special offer specifically for the David
Pakman show audience if you click the
link under this video you'll get $200
off the cryptocurrency starter kit check
it out using the link down below